you
the Council of the Arts yes and we
remain in my opinion one of the most
important legacies of dr. Jerome reason
Council for the Arts at MIT was founded
by K Stratton and Jerry Wiesner Jerry
was totally devoted to the art so that
he picked up the little art committee
and made it into the council for the
arts Jerry was a very strong entire
nuclear person he was President Kennedy
science advisor and felt that
institutions like MIT were turning out a
lot of students and graduates of very
high technical expertise who had a
fairly large probability of destroying
the world and it was very important to
get involved in things that have some
sense of humanity they found that MIT
really had tremendous strength in the
arts and the arts perhaps we're not
getting the kind of residence the kind
of his ability they should and ought to
have because they thought of the Arts is
very much part of the mainstream of MIT
very much part of the core mission when
the council was created 40 years ago it
was almost unique there may have been
one or two others if its kind where else
but at MIT we like going first
the view at that point which is very
strange looking back is if we're going
to do art let's buy some and put it out
in the campus in retrospect that was
brilliant public art collections on
University campuses were ranked back in
2006 and MIT was in the top 10 and we
love showing off this public art
collection the two most recent pieces
acquired was a niche kapoor's sculpture
which is over in the Stata Center and
Jack buck Jones at the Sloan School
the grants programs the most vital thing
cam it does over the course of the years
we've given over a thousand grants away
several million dollars a lot of the
money we give allows these people to get
money from other people probably two to
three two one these grants impacted my
work in ways that I had to think about
community these grants are meant to
provide for interaction between students
and faculty it's just Alexa and this is
where a lot of my work has evolved the
council is very important that it
supports the arts here in many different
aspects and carrying the work of art to
the world and allowing us to develop and
flourish in the Institute so thank you
cannot support of the MIT museum and the
list Visual Arts Center is another
wonderful dimension we give money to the
BSO so the MIT students could get
tickets there either free or cheap money
to the garden of museums in to the mfa
we give money every year to the
artist-in-residence program
all of my interactions with the council
have been student focused we've had
residences where artists will come in
and work with the ensembles
Joe Lovano was probably one of the
greatest tenor saxophone soloist in jazz
and we were able to get him to come to
MIT
and the students rose to the occasion it
was a wonderful example how when they're
in the presence of a great master they
just lift and lift and lift the
McDermott award was founded by Margaret
McDermott the widow of Eugene McDermott
the founder of Texas Instruments mrs.
McDermott decided after Jean died that
she would like to give an award every
year to artists that are mid-career let
me confess I love Santo Domingo I love
coming home to the guys in Blazers
trying to push little cups of brugal
into my hands and it has attracted
wonderful people Junot Diaz who we later
recruited to our faculty prominent New
Yorker writer Pulitzer Prize winner
Diller Scofidio two architects who were
unknown at the time they were brought to
campus later became world-class
architects and are among other things
the architects of the ICA in all cases
the people who get the award spent some
time at MIT with the students in some
classes it's like learning baseball from
Babe Ruth
but don't be nervous you know for the
young conductor Los Angeles Philharmonic
was Louisville dudamel came here to
receive the award audience most recently
robert lepage the canadian theatre
maestro everything he does it all with
experience we've learned that we should
not force connections we let them and
eventually to three things seems to go
together and go oh there's a pattern
there and so the award has really
evolved from a nice award to an
important intermediate artist award to
one of the highest level awards in the
world kamut has always been an
organization that socially bonds that
goes on trips has wonderful art trips
getting into very exclusive private
galleries we've been to pry we've been
to Berlin we've been der Chicago it's
not at the cutting edge of art it to the
cutting edge of people I mean you're
meeting very smart people among the most
important reasons one should join Cabot
is you get closer to a truly great
institution of higher learning
at MIT we are very much oriented toward
art at the intersection of science and
technology to find out what can we do
that will change the world the best
works that are developed in our classes
here come from students who are
brilliant people from mathematics
material science or mechanical
engineering art opens their view and
possibilities beyond the problem solving
agenda
kamut has been generous to MIT it is the
single most important sponsor of the
Arts the Council for the Arts at MIT
gives an additional voice to the Arts
it's this kind of nourishment that the
council provides that really makes a
difference in what we're able to do it's
about a concern about what the arts mean
at MIT